>> This might be a bit surprising but sometimes in math we can just ignore
certain things. If we ignore the negative sign, what we're really doing is
taking the absolute value of these. So we're just looking at the positive
distance of each value from the mean. If we multiply each deviation by 2, we'll
still have negative deviations, or negative double deviations now, and positive
double deviations, and the negatives and positives will still cancel out.
However, we can square each deviation. A negative times a negative is a
positive. If we multiply this number by itself, we'll get a positive number. And
a positive times a positive is also a positive. So we'll end up with some
positive square deviations. There's always something we can do, never give up.